non maman c'est samedi soir merde mais
dis donc Jésus
c'est quoi ces gros mots là
et
ça tu restes à la maison ce soir j'ai
juste 12 copains qui attendent que
j'arrive au restaurant et c'est le
moment que tu choisis pour me faire une
scène tu sais ses copains Jean Thomas
Mathieu
Simon Pierre c'est celui qui ressemble à
une fille là
je suis un peu la grappe on est en l'an
33 ce serait peut-être temps d'avoir une
vision un peu large toi et papa vous
avez pas hésité à faire une PMA avec
l'aide de Dieu pour arrondir les fins de
moi donc si ça se savait je sais pas
trop comment ça serait pris
je vous le dis on est en train de vivre
le Mitou de l'humour et oui aujourd'hui
on peut plus rien dire ça devient
difficile non seulement parfois les
humoristes sont censurés sur les
plateaux téléven punis mais maintenant
parfois ils sont même censurés dans leur
spectacle où on les interdit jouer on
leur enlève leur spectacle parce que on
pense qu'ils ont à dérapé donc on va en
parler et pour ça on a quand même celui
qui a écrit pour Bernard parle pour
tirer le Luron Bernard Mabille
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
le professeur Rollin
et un petit jeune et c'est très rare il
est drôle et beau c'est rare
non pardon
c'est pour ça je dis ça et vous vous
êtes et en plus vous êtes beaux bah
merci si tu veux on peut rentrer
ensemble allez
j'en ai fait tout même en faire tourner
mon
téléphone pour moi c'est ça que tu as
dit
il a déjà tout compris du métier alors
Bernard commence un petit peu avec vous
d'abord on vous retrouve le 22 janvier
il y a votre spectacle Isabelle miraculé
à gravançant le 29 janvier il y a toutes
les dates tout ça vous êtes sur scène
mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est que à
l'époque
à l'époque alors il monte encore il y a
6 mois il y a 6 mois j'ai l'impression
que la la censure c'était les politiques
on ne pouvait rien dire sur les
politiques sinon on était viré c'est
vrai un peu ouais et aujourd'hui la
censure bah c'est les femmes c'est la
religion c'est les gays et on ne fait
plus que des blagues en fonction de
cette communauté que sur les politiques
et on est rentable que sur les
politiciens et eux ne disent rien enfin
oui eux en redemande même on redemande
ils sont tellement contents d'être
reconnus par leur boulangère
et faire du buzz donc rappeler qu'à
l'époque vous étiez critique vous et
vous avez critiqué dit du mal de tirer
le Luron qui un jour son téléphone et
qui dit bah plus que tu es plus de que
les autres écrits pour moi et
visiblement vous êtes plus vieux que les
autres puisque vous avez écrit pour lui
et notamment ça a donné cette séquence
qu'on a beaucoup vu mais qui était
génial c'est Michel Drucker alors que
c'était il y avait il y avait mon roi il
y avait tous les socialistes qui étaient
là il avait repris l'important c'est la
rose en l'emmerdant c'est la rose
regardez
je déteste
[Musique]
rose au centre la France est au goutte à
goutte sans détente plutôt que coûte
pour longtemps
[Musique]
évidemment
c'est bientôt là tant que vous te car
c'est déjà la déroute
[Musique]
c'est la rose
tout le monde connaît
et à l'époque
en ce moment mais ce qui est drôle c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est faire tout le monde
serait ça à l'époque ça
effectivement vous en étiez pris à des
musulmans aujourd'hui ou à la religion
et tout ça ça a choqué il y avait deux
personnes qui allaient loin à l'époque
il y avait bon je passe sur Charlie
Hebdo qui existait déjà qui a ouvert une
voie énorme et les deux personnes c'est
connu chez Le Luron quoi mais la
question plus simple en fait est-ce qu'à
l'époque on était ça a juste changé on a
juste changé les thématiques mais ce
qu'on était plus est-ce que finalement
on pouvait rire de tout à l'époque
puisque aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui on
peut rire de tous
mais moi je peux vous dire que je mesure
où ça fait rire les autres
questions est posée de changer la donne
mais François je dis quelque chose
François le nom du Maurice qu'on a reçu
ici dans TPMP je vous dirai pas les noms
mais qui me disent moi par exemple dans
les spectacle musulman
bouge pas je vous explique la meilleure
réponse parce qu'on a fait mille
émissions sur Peut-On rire de tout la
meilleure réponse elle a été donnée par
Benoît de l'épine ce garçon avec lequel
bien sûr créer les Guignols canal en 90
c'est on ne peut rire que de tout
c'est-à-dire que dès que vous essayez de
mettre une limite vous comment le rire
n'existe pas
chaque humoriste selon sa morale
personnelle peut choisir de faire rire
François vous savez combien me tour
aujourd'hui c'est parce que aujourd'hui
on est en train de juger le passé avec
les yeux d'aujourd'hui le dernier
scandale qui moi m'a horrifié dites-moi
ce que vous en pensez c'est Michel Leeb
regardez le sketch de Michel Leeb à
l'époque il faisait l'Africain et le
pour Michel Leeb maintenant il est c'est
un pestiféré partout et on lui tombe
dessus souvenez-vous parce qu'à l'époque
tout le monde se marrait avant de le
critiquer
[Applaudissements]
allô qu'est-ce que
dans l'avion j'avais une petite faim
alors j'ai demandé la liste des
passagers
qu'il est tombé dessus en disant que
c'était une honte totale totale c'est ma
question il y avait Baudour
c'est Sophie Daumier les vacances à
Marrakech est-ce qu'on peut juger
l'humour derrière la société
d'aujourd'hui moi je pense qu'on
pourrait de tout avec n'importe qui ça
dépend du talent et comment ça amener et
moi j'en suis sur cette droite à partir
du moment où on met une limite c'est la
limite qui devait encore plus drôle mais
moi mais moi ce que je trouve bizarre
c'est par exemple il y a des personnes
encore plus loin un peu plus développé
en fait les gros qui des gros ça dérange
personne qui font des Vans sur les
Arabes sur les c'est toujours
mieux pris et pourquoi on peut pas se
mélanger
pourquoi ça va courte parce que
justement il mélange tout et attends
juste une seconde parce qu'il y a un
truc il y a un truc qui m'intéresse il
est arrivé il y a pas longtemps un
garçon qui s'appelle Gaëtan Mathis je
sais pas si vous connaissez très bien
c'est un ami cette année à toi alors tu
approche pas trop
il avait sucé une vague daddination il
est au Point Virgule Point Virgule je
l'ai rappelé il y a eu Bigard il y a eu
palmadies tous les plus grands ont
commencé au Point Virgule il avait
publié une vanne sur les réseaux sociaux
en octobre 2001 une VAN sur
Eric Zemmour voilà qui est passé je vous
montre la vanne ce qu'il a dit si
j'avais une machine à voyager dans le
temps je bouclerai le Bataclan pour la
soirée du 13 novembre 2015 afin d'y
organiser une soirée rencontre entre ere
Zemmour et son public non seulement il y
a du s'excuser mais c'est là où ça va
plus loin c'est que qu'on s'excuse dans
Télé mais c'est que le le Point Virgule
ce soir-là l'annuler oui mais c'est
voilà le problème c'est ça c'est une
question de timing il y a un moment
donné il faut attendre un petit peu
c'est un peu trop tôt encore le Bataclan
justement pour que je pense
jeune et tout tu vois il aurait un passé
un machin tout à fait à l'époque ça
pouvait faire rire mais quand vous me
dites de proches des proches il est pas
méconnu on cite des proches mais des
proches au bout de 40 ans qui voulaient
mais au début de sa carrière pour dire
un truc aussi violent il faut vraiment
que ce soit hyper hyper hyper
intéressant c'est le support qui est pas
bon à l'écrit les vannes ne marche
jamais faut l'incarner faut la vivre il
faut lui donner un temps c'est l'ami
d'Alexis donc toi tu l'as rencontré ce
matin
c'est un gars très sympa et cetera et
après il en raconte il en fait un sketch
d'ailleurs qui est très drôle sur cette
anecdote c'est qu'il dit qu'il est sur
ses chiottes en train de faire une story
il a 3000 abonnés il écrit cette vanne
il s'en tape il l'a publie et au final
ça repart sur Twitter Zemmour qui est en
pleine expérience à ce moment-là tout le
monde parle de lui il la reprend il l'a
politique et c'est comme ça qu'il se
fait des ennemis donc c'est dommage
il a fait sur scène et quand il l'a fait
sur scène et marcher apparemment donc
s'il avait peut-être publié un extrait
sur scène avec un rire peut-être que ce
serait pas parce que je veux dire
quelque chose prenez un mec et là je
m'intéressais à François aussi mais
prenez un mec comme gaz par Proust
Gaspard ça va loin on ne le va alors ça
va très loin
mais vous savez quoi on ne le voit
jamais à la télé et une Twitter rien
chronique
sur une grande radio alors François
Rollin évidemment parle de vous aussi
vous connaît pour des personnages
incroyables Kaamelott Palace merci
Palace ton mais ici même il y a
oui
ça doit vous saouler en même temps tout
le monde me connaît voilà donc vous avez
co-écrit aussi beaucoup de spectacles de
sa mère Pierre Palmade là-dessous
Jean-Marie Bigard Guy Carlier Vincent
Dedienne si vous dire le talent et en
2015 sur la scène de l'Européen vous
mettez les pieds dans le plat vous aussi
en abordant des sujets politiquesment
incorrects où on apprend qu'il est
normal d'avoir peur de l'Islam vous vous
attaquez à l'Islam
cette année là et certains disent que
depuis ce moment là et vous en avez
partagé chez Jordan Deluxe oui j'en ai
parlé vous avez moins la carte et même
vous vous l'avez dit ça vend plus
François Rollin oui c'est un peu un peu
résumé mais effectivement les biens pas
ensemble ce sont empressés de se lever
et de transformer d'ailleurs ce que j'ai
dit parce que j'ai dit qu'on pouvait
comprendre que des gens aient peur de
l'Islam juste dit ça et d'ailleurs j'ai
dit à un autre moment du spectacle qu'on
pouvait comprendre que des gens se
disent que l'immigration leur posait
problème j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait
faire il fallait chasser les immigrés
j'ai même pas dit qu'il fallait les
montrer du doigt j'ai juste dit ça
comprendre ce que font les gens parce
que ce que vont les biens pensants c'est
que quand ils vont un endroit où ça sent
mauvais ils mettent un couvercle et puis
on oublie qu'on en parle pas et moi je
dis bah si il y a des Français qui ont
un problème avec ça et il faut qu'il
soit entendu il faut qu'on leur prenne
ne serait-ce que pour leur dire que ils
ont tort d'avoir un problème avec ça et
que on peut le régler sans aucune
violence un humoriste il incarne quelque
chose la force de Gad Elmaleh c'est ce
que je veux dire émission c'est pas
seulement les textes si on avait tous un
auteur ça serait facile c'est comment
les interprète c'est qui il est vous
pour les gens vous êtes de l'humour un
peu absurde un peu intelligent donc
quand vous parlez de ça on se dit pas
forcément que c'est drôle on se dit plus
professeur Ronin nous explique quelque
chose est-ce que vous voyez ce que je
veux dire bah oui ou non c'est pas très
gênant c'est à dire que c'est le rôle
d'un humoriste aussi c'est de réfléchir
de transmettre de partager une pensée un
humoriste c'est pas un clown c'est pas
c'est pas un amuseur de fin de banquet
c'est quelqu'un qui réfléchit qui pense
et qui propose des voilà Dany Boon qui a
très gentiment préfacé un de mes
bouquins mon copain Dany Boon bah lui
aussi d'accord il fait il fait rigoler
mais il fait rigoler mais il y a une
pensée de Dany Boon si il y a une pensée
si si pardon et d'ailleurs non c'est pas
du tout méchant je vais l'Olympia c'est
drôle on n'est pas sur on part pas en
disant tiens j'ai une réflexion du monde
différente
sur les sur les rapports les gens et
c'est tout d'ailleurs et alors pardon
Bernard aussi vous avez écrit aussi pour
qui est une femme extrêmement populaire
mais qu'on n'est jamais la carte un peu
on disait elle remplissait des salles
mais grosso modo il y avait un petit
côté un peu si tu veux un nouveau-nov tu
es un peu ringard et c'est normalement
je l'ai amené vers la politique vous
l'avez amené vers la politique votre
spécialité chez Drucker et la meuf s'est
mis avant la carte incroyable avec les
fameux bistrots comment faire
et vous coécriviez il y a pas que moi
même si je crois que depuis vous n'êtes
pas un sacré pognon de quoi vous depuis
vous entendez pas trop au début ou
depuis depuis ah non on s'entend quand
même
[Rires]
c'était plus facile de bosser si vous
êtes très dur sur le terrible du bureau
c'est une travailleuse travailleuse
travailleuse 3 heures du mat tu avais un
mail disant faut changer tel mot tel
machin mais temps
elle a fait sur ce pont
il écrit tout cet texte c'est peut-être
son erreur mais il écrit tout ses textes
et je racontais l'histoire en trois
secondes je suis à Las Vegas l'année
dernière la ville la plus vulgaire du
monde est riche et Cher pardon donc je
m'ennuie énormément les gens sont
vulgaires ils ont des espèces de
débardeur des claquettes à l'heure du
déjeuner bref je chope le covid je suis
dans une espèce de chambre mercure
pardon pour mercure immonde pas froide
et je m'ennuie j'ai le covid je prends
mon téléphone je vois les réels arrive
sur mes réels ce garçon au début j'y
tiens ça peut être un plan et en fait je
vois qu'il me fait rire
et pendant deux jours je regarde tout
tout c'est réel et ce mec est un coup de
cœur et je rentre à Paris et je viens te
voir et je vais quand même vous montrer
un peu ce qui est Alexis traboni et
parce que je pense vraiment Bernard ça
peut vous intéresser aussi c'est quelque
chose que j'ai jamais vu justement tu
tapes sur tout le monde alors que tu
n'es nigai ni et Bani noir ni maghrébin
ni musulman ni féministe et ça t'a plu
synonyme donc elle est conne et
homophobe alors que j'ai jamais parlé
des homosexuels comment
en gros si quelqu'un est offensé parce
qu'il sait pas comment consommer une
blague c'est pas mon problème on
poursuit pas le fabricant quand un génie
boit de l'eau de javel
et le mec qui fait c'est que tous les
jours il dit la presse et il part d'un
chiffre à chaque fois et à partir d'une
d'un pourcentage ou quoi il en fait un
truc il y a les non-binaires aussi alors
les nominaires et les yeux aussi tu peux
y aller tu peux lancer on se régale
allez non-binaire là
va faire un qui est-ce avec un non
binaire
c'est un homme ou une femme un homme
mais qu'est-ce qu'il dit que c'est un
homme oh là là
[Applaudissements]
expression de genre oh là là
je vais me détendre et voilà qui elle me
casse les couilles et on vous parle de
plus soft mais le gars il dit tout
il parle même de l'actu là c'est sur
Normal j'espère qu'il nous regarde pas
parce qu'il en garde à vue quand j'étais
petit j'avais j'avais une chatte
maintenant je l'ai plus je fasse si
différent des trans finalement
elle est morte à 16 ans elle est morte à
16 ans en parlant de chatte de 16 ans
quelqu'un a des news de Norman ou
ah
je vous en fait deux derniers parce que
vraiment
professeur Rollin institution Bernard
Mabille vous le voyez évidemment vous
l'entendre une légende des boules donc
c'est pas que je vous aime pas je n'ai
plus rien à vendre vous avez tout gagné
le petit je vais être son Drucker que
dans quelques années il m'a fait faire
sa première télé son Philippe Bouvard
hein
moi je le suis
donc
Bill Cosby par le site Bill Cosby
regardez Bill Cosby il a payé 4 millions
de dollars à une de ses victimes qu'il
avait mis un doigt et ok c'est horrible
[Musique]
4 millions de dollars le roi de
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
et on va te juger sur l'intention et ça
ça ne se définit pas par des mots on va
sentir l'intention quand des proches dis
je crois que des Juifs se sont glissés
dans la salle pourquoi ça passe parce
que
40 ans
très bien professeur vous faites une
blague aujourd'hui là à l'antenne sur
les Juifs je vous promets qu'on a un
scandale dans la dans l'après-midi ça
dépend quel est le blog ça dépend
comment je l'amène
c'est passé justement au Molière il y a
quelques années avec Blanche Gardin qui
a repris la blague de Desproges en
disant il paraît qu'il y a des Juifs
dans la salle donc pendant la série des
Molière et les gens ont ri et c'est très
bien passé et c'était justement sur le
même sujet et elle a dit drôle ou pas
drôle il est animateur mais il était
aussi humoriste puisqu'il montait sur
scène et moi j'ai énormément de respect
pour les gens qui montent sur scène
parce que j'ai voulu le faire j'ai un
petit défaut dans la vie j'ai pas de
courage et oui c'est vrai je vous le dis
peut-être pas le talent non plus il
fallait les deux choses ça c'est pas
fait
non mais c'est vrai que j'aurai à deux
il faut il faut du courage pour moi sur
scène donc drôle ou pas drôle il faut du
courage texte qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime
pas c'est un humain
là on ne juge pas l'animateur on juge
l'hum mais c'était pas drôle c'est pas
la question c'était subjectif mais c'est
pas la question c'est subjectif
quelle est ma question professeur Rollin
merci heureusement voilà merci la
question drôle ou pas drôle on s'en fout
c'est subjectif humour sinon voilà
humoriste qui a fait une blague en
plateau est-ce que ça méritait que c'est
ça ce vide et qu'il soit viré en aucun
cas merci tu es là en aucun cas il
méritait pas d'être viré comme ça
mes petites informations on peut dire
que ils avaient d'autres raisons de
virer texte et ils ont pris ce prétexte
au fond le public le public de texte
n'est pas dupe et n'a jamais adhéré au
fait qu'on les viré le public de texte a
dit mais non c'est une blague s'il l'a
pas inventé depuis longtemps
il m'a dit derrière après que les femmes
c'est sales ont été vite vite vite les
femmes ont été ont été virées parce que
là où là c'est pas l'institution qui
l'empêche de remplir ces salles c'est
que son public n'attire plus à ça parce
que il y a un truc que je me posais
comme question Alexis moi je ressens
d'aller j'ai ri de tout comme vous je
fais partie de votre génération et tout
me faisait rire j'ai des gosses qu'on 27
25 19 et 19 et bah eux quand je fais des
blagues parfois
choqué c'est papa tu en as un peu marre
de ces blagues là toujours
l'exploitation
qui fait attention à ce qu'on continue
pas de développer des clichés y compris
dans les blagues parfois sur le sexisme
et je pense que moi
je suis désolé quand tu vois un mec
comme Olivier de Benoist tu peux tu peux
tu peux aimer les femmes et rire aux
trucs d'Olivier de Benoît
sur le site d'ennuyeux quand on fait de
l'humour sur quelqu'un parce qu'on n'ose
pas le faire sur les yeux c'est pas une
blague mais par exemple un gars qui fait
un scandale avec les catholiques comme
Benjamin Ledig il s'en prend une il
prend une Taulé derrière c'est pas une
blague du tout merci
les catholiques qui se défendent comme
ce se défendre les musulmans les Juifs
etc le tout c'est d'avoir une bonne
intention d'être là de pour donner de
l'amour en fait c'est qu'est-ce qu'il y
a derrière ta blague alors j'ai une
petite j'ai un petit cadeau pour vous
j'ai un petit cadeau pour vous juste un
mot est-ce qu'on peut faire un petit peu
de promo ah oui on peut faire alors
allez-y alors j'ai trois bouquins qui
sont bien drôles un bouquin qui
s'appelle suis-je bête qui est préfacé
par Alexandre Astier qui a une réflexion
sur la bêtise qui est géniale
d'intellectuel Laurent dictionnaire
amoureux de la bêtise où vous
retrouverez d'ailleurs des amis à nous
puisque dans ce livre je ne dénonce pas
ceux qui sont bêtes mais je dénonce ceux
qui ne le sont pas ceux qui ont fait une
réputation d'être idiot bien sûr donc
vous trouverez notre camarade Benjamin
Castaldi ou note
[Applaudissements]
sur une réputation
qu'ils ne sont pas du tout donc pour
savoir bien qui est bête faut savoir
aussi qui ne l'est pas ça je voudrais
l'offrir à Isabelle et le troisième
bouquin et puis ça c'est pour vous
vraiment Mathieu parce que les mémoires
d'un gros mytho c'est
regarde pourquoi tu fais pour vous c'est
parce que je raconte comment tout ce que
les tout ce qui compte depuis Paul en
France c'est de passer seulement 10
minutes avec moi et moi je vous
conseille de temps en temps et je suis
toujours déçu ça c'est adorable on te
voit où et quand au Point Virgule les
mercredis et en tournée dans toute la
France quand
il y a Bretagne Lyon tu m'avais pas dit
ça s'apparente
ton producteur et je m'occupais un petit
peu de l'oseille il est pas là pour rien
voilà et j'aimerais vous faire un petit
cadeau juste pour terminer un petit peu
de Bernard Mabille dans les grosses
têtes j'écoute ça tous les soirs en
podcast et je vous adore écouter
tu as pas vu ton zizi mais Bernard même
en érection ça ne dépasse pas
en érection c'est autre chose non mais
c'est histoire
une petite femme elle devient bossu
[Rires]
c'est vous dire quand même on n'arrive
pas à trouver tu vois bien croire
[Rires]
la révolte des boudins
il s'est retrouvé très dépourvu et il a
fait appel à des pizzas
[Rires]
donc j'aimerais bien voir ma bille en
peignoir ça va être sympa ça non je te
dire pourquoi c'est sympa parce que j'en
ai aucun qui ferme
[Applaudissements]